welcome to this video for round five
coverage of the candidates tournament
and this is some a game between Dimitri
and Reagan and vision hunt playing black
yeah edit some of course a matchup of
two players with very different
tournament while almond um yeah being in
an in really bad shape before the
tournament started brilliantly with two
wins and he's in a very good position in
the tournament and I draken yeah bit of
an outsider not really a favorite but I
had him on my list of possible dark
horses and well okay he just lost two
games and um yeah it does not really
seem to be in great shape so what is
fishy going to do is he don't you do
something extraordinary to beat and
Drake in with black let's see what
happens okay no Sicilian the some yeah
this she mostly plays a five and c5 so
you don't know let's see and it's the
Berlin and I must say unfortunately yeah
well this is a great practical opening
and then tournament chess for black I
really think so I mean you have very
very good chances to equalize the game
and compared to many other lines you
really have somewhat easy life and lots
of lines and it's for the commentator
and spectator quite often not so
exciting simply um yeah what is android
can smooth p.m. he played d3 simply
covering the e4 pawn it seems that the
endgame is less and less popular I mean
what I'm talking about is of course this
the endgame variation
classical chat role in ball and game yet
this is not so much seen nowadays why
players really am yeah seem to get
nowhere in the end game and this is why
they look for alternative routes and
drinking playing d3 this is a bit of
vermin yeah you can speculate what and
Reagan's idea about this game is as you
want to just play a drawer as you want
to get a prolonged fight d3 is a bit of
a middle of the road approach it it
still keeps keeps pieces on the board if
you want to just draw the game just to
be a cynic about that castling that if
one rookie one and I don't really see a
like playing for whenever in this in
this type of structure we have seen this
in the world championship match as well
so d3 plate an honored place Bishop c5
just the probably the best movement
opposition developing the bishop
actively and now we're drinking to go
and see six this has been also played by
cars recently very young technical type
of move getting to a somewhat defined
bone structure and very often clay
evolves around those kind of poem breaks
like f form yeah but I'm draken is it's
not going for that type of strategy
plays Bishop e3 offering further trade
um yeah here are not actually places
somewhat rare a move surprisingly I was
surprised to see that play Bishop takes
III and this is actually less oops I
keep pressing this button um should be
three the capture is actually less
popular than Bishop to d6 this has been
seen far more often with black keeping
the bishop pair for the time being but
yeah well the bishop has nice to have
but the bishops are not
brilliant in the structure anyway it's
very closed and down I think that Bishop
takes you three it's a very decent
alternative a white captured and black
played Queenie seven to keep if I've
protected about the you five point I'm
just showing it again after this white
cannot take because of Queen d4 and you
will loose material night as a tech tend
to mate on f2 yeah ok here now this you
must protect the pony plate Queenie
seven castles castles and Queenie one
that's actually an interesting move I
mean it's very early Queen move it has
some points white is toying with two
ideas you can switch the Queen over and
maybe use the F file it's not like it's
a quick King side attack with a quick
mate but yeah you can shift your
attention to their to the Kings side or
the Queen like after 98 from some black
good move i think the Queen can again go
over here to see three to attack the
porn and initiate some play on the
queenside this is in fact what under 18
is going from Queen c3f 6y le5 was
hanging and now be four young he wants
to gain space on the queenside yeah
ideas like that might come into play the
night over to see 5 or see form at the
right moment and yeah it's it's a decent
plan 96 very understandable the night
needs to get back into play and it's a
good position on the sex I will if it
keeps some pressure on e four so that d
4 is not easily playable it looks at be
five so that this kind of tech is not so
simple and it has a look at f5 which
really discourages any ideas like night
45 I mean this does not really fit with
the Queen position anyway but it's a
good position on d6 for the night it's
not a very common position in this
structure but it seems like a good one
yeah and Drake in playing a form yeah to
discuss this position a bit what is the
general strategy that both players can
go for the thing is i believe it's quite
tricky in this position to do anything
constructive on your own it's um it's
really not easy look at the pawn
structure we have every or pawns are
still on the board and therefore it is a
relatively closed position with those
half opened files the D file and the fr
but there is not much happening on those
those files what is the great idea
they're very difficult to get anything
on those so what is left in the position
palm breaks yes mentioned d4 it's tricky
to play as it we can see for so much um
yeah b5 is an idea that white can go for
and in fact he has played a 42 maybe
support that the black has this grip on
b5 so this is not easily played as well
and yeah White has a hard time to really
to do anything here and unfortunately
for the spectator the same applies for
black black and also had don't does not
really have great bone breaks f5 Hanks
the e5 pawn and on the queenside I mean
why does just a bit bit stronger on the
queenside so you don't have any way to
to do something there and if you cannot
use palm breaks in the position you
won't make any any substantial progress
it's really a game that that both
players need to play off just a solid
stay flexible and if the other side is
sort of blinking you need to be ready to
to punish a possible mistake we see it
that both players
complete development b6 is a move that
controlled c5 and and a five for the
moment and if white now it's not yeah
right now it's not alert he played a
five the right move I guess if Y
displaying a roof like nothing just to
show it then black would have a five
yeah it's easy to see that white needs
to attend to this position of thread but
still it's a little threat as a five
view why is it the front ya know White
has no way to to keep his pawn structure
clean he needs to probably take
otherwise black will take and play c5 to
expose for as a weakness and after the
capture I mean okay probably even even
this is going to end in some
simplification but in certainly nothing
that white has dreamt about before okay
he played a 5m said this is logical
anyway as you might open up the a file
for your rook yet I'm plays an
interesting move quick eh eh to wait and
after look H we plays through a v8 and
this is a slight um a little bit of a
slight provocation simply because yeah
it gives up the a file and it's not
clear what black is getting in return
however what we see in the game after
the capture and further some some
maneuvering here white got to a seven
later and really didn't didn't gain much
I need to talk about this this for mode
white plate Queen a one sort of
preparing this and looking at the a8
square so that rook e8 it's not playable
after Queen a one I don't like night b7
this prepares the c5 booth black likes
to get rid of his some double porn yeah
Quincy three back and here are none
could have played 96 just repeating the
position yeah for possible draw note
that they cannot draw the game due to
rules
before move 30 so the only way to to
make a draw before that really is a
perpetual check or repetition and here
they could have gone obviously could
have gone for this type of repetition
you never know if and raking would have
played on and just but Quincy 3 is a bit
of a signal okay Adam I to draw here so
what did on a Duke plate c5 soap writing
on not repeating and after takes into
with the the knight on d5 so the night
now is on c5 instead of d6 but it still
has this useful pressure to prevent any
action in the center yeah ruga a7 was
played and now look f2c 8 and now we see
that this look to be 8 which allowed y
to enter on a seven yeah it has given
what this active rook but how much does
it really mean in terms of concrete
progress it's not the same um black has
this easily covered the seaborne and
term it's not clear what white really
has achieved you played look here and
now I'll play d 5 which is an
interesting move really this sort of
forces the commitment by white the thing
is if you play nothing move I'll just
use this King edge one again um you need
to reckon with the idea to put the night
on a 4 and this would actually
disconnect both rooks the night on a
form is somewhat disturbing the harmony
behind White's pieces if you look at the
position like that like might go here
claro que 8 and maybe Quincy five this
starts to get hmm a little bit
uncomfortable I'm not saying that black
is largely better or anything but black
has made some progress with the night on
a force strange as it looks but it helps
to as mentioned disturb White's
coordination a bit
so I think I Drake he needs to be a
carefully and the King ashwin is
obviously nonsense he needs to do
something concrete and and circumspect
here he played deform um I think
actually that Queen before is the easier
move to to just keep it completely
completely simple it forces blacks reply
white is building up this the spin with
the idea of playing I'd be three winning
material so black must react to that to
Queen d6s the only good move here Queen
f8 in comparison is not good because of
d4 yeah we can see that after Queen d6
Queen d6 you right now place deform
black has this tactical this tactical
idea it's not just winning important
because white will get e 5 backward this
is the idea to meet deform what white
can do though you can play with like
night b3 and after takes and takes um I
think this should be quite okay for
white I mean you cannot hope for
anything in terms of an edge but with
the the a file under your control your
certainty I never going to Beaver cm I
think this is actually somewhat simpler
than what and raking played he played
deform you know not allowing this
development that I mentioned before with
night a for disturbing um White's
coordination yeah here are not took on
deform and took on e4 and this is I
think just the the best way to go about
it he just took the offer porn it's not
a permanent win of material because
after the trade and Drake into conscious
seven this is obviously what he had
calculated before and well how to assess
this position it's um probably about
equal with with very precise play where
white it's it's it's a bit uncomfortable
alrighty i think that the queen before
move was was easier but okay let's see
what happens now on earth is now playing
Bishop to f5 makes much sense putting
pressure on c2 and then Reagan went for
luke a to a seven yeah doubling on the
seventh a very sensible move yeah note
that blacks position has 11 serious
drawback and technical problem this is
the back rank and this is the
explanation for the mean age six it's a
very human move to play in fact here
aren't an alternative and maybe this was
a more testing way to play but it's it's
not easy for a human to do you really
want your gear lift for the king yeah
twin c2 in an interesting way to go
after the trade like is upon up for the
moment and the interesting thing is that
the normal looking move rook takes g7 is
leading to some problems after before
black has this excellent bishop that
covers the age seven pawn and yeah the
vporn it is just very dangerous I mean
white must do something like that and
fight on from there but it's it's tricky
to play really there are ideas black can
try rook aah here for example and get
this and now the capture is of course
not possible black can just take on b3
the route 107 eggs so it's this is
tricky and the cleanest way for white
here is actually not to take on g7 but
to play the somewhat strange looking new
fruit a to be seven
yeah the idea is simply taking on CA
taking on b5 take-take-take here now
that's the idea and black eye only has
this this type of move to keep the pawn
for the moment and after that in fact
King the king approach f-22 III will
probably lead to a draw anyway but this
is not easy to find rook a to be seven I
mean okay it's not it's not rocket
science and then raking at some time but
maybe this was an interesting way to try
and unplayed h6 and this is in fact
right very human um of course and this
type of move can often be more more
dangerous for the opponent than a
forcing move because um especially when
time gets lower this is not a factor yet
and Drake in as 27 minutes but if time
gets lowered sometimes better to plan on
forcing moves and actually give the
opponent many year possibilities to
consider then play a forcing move that
after which he only needs to find that
the only reply possible so age sixes may
be a good good idea just from a
practical point of view to let white
make moves and try to benefit from not
so accurate play let Queen d2 yeah Queen
on c3 retreated possibly also covering
this of course yeah whoops e7 Roxy seven
and Bishop g4 yeah the night on a three
years not to well-placed like as
attending to capture it and now black
has a slight initiative with the more
active pieces I think the next moves are
pretty I'm pretty solid and normal roots
III to maybe take with the rook before
was played look III and Queen back to d5
so we see that black has this this
activity it's got a good Queen on d5 and
he has the sea pawn to to attack on the
other hand before is also not
strong it can easily fall if black
decides to activate the rook and he
needs the rook in the upcoming peace
play 2 to get anywhere so h3 was played
Bishop f5 of course keeping pieces on
the board keeping the pressure on yeah
now i'm dragging rook be 3 to attack be
four tier quincy falls plane yeah you
can also look at roxy ATM which which i
did after the capture by the Queen black
wall will get this back and um yeah at
first it looks quite quite comfortable
for black but it seems that queen bee
seven here just trades enough material
to secure the draw right still has some
this is a slightly weak porn but it's
not not a big issue a plate Quincy for
just keeping before protected and get
the tech on the sea porn would be to not
happy move but cannot give up situ and
be sure before I we see that Arnold is
really making progress here he has taken
over in this game quite quite clearly
king f2 and now he took on f3 which i
think is ok it was not necessary to do
it you can also just keep keep the
pieces on the board player strengthening
moves but I think it was a good decision
and now I'm it's actually critical it
seems that G takes f is not such a bad
move but it's not a move that you really
like to make as human player damaging
your pawn structure and the long run all
four pawns look we can of course before
as mentioned there is a counter-attack
on that but still it does not feel so
great in this position you played King
takes and maybe g
it was actually better and they don't
know after King takes on here are none
played a rook v5 which I believe um yeah
this is not accurate Queen a chance
check it seems was some was more testing
after that y term really must be very
careful on to to defend um what is the
point the check now I mean the king is
obviously exposed and if Y place between
f2 let's start with that to block the
check there's this move and that is very
annoying now attacking the rook and
keeping this attacked so what what
should why do we should go here there's
a rook c8 and you have that check on the
C porn why takes group takes and this
this will get a look at very very ugly
the Queen does not really have a good
square also like it's just just winning
here so you cannot play the Queen really
to have to a very tricky and after that
there is rook e8 intending rookie to and
white now as in food defense mode and as
normal it's tricky to do to just defend
yeah against this rookie to he probably
should play see form probably see form
and now I'm yeah there are there's more
than one good idea that black can try
can try to push be three years white
cannot take again on because of rookie
to black can also try to to get the F
corn involved at some stage or rookie
form the combination of white somewhat
shaky King the be poor and those weak
pawns on c4 and deform and really give
black some substantial winning chances i
believe if you take this is also
something to consider however it's not
so clear what blacks next move is you
to be porn to distract right so maybe
after see for this really be three is
the interesting way to go um yeah
come-in c3 maybe that's f5 and then they
also f4 check now this check check
however is it wrong yeah I believe that
so that is what when a nun should have
tried the Queen check here for practical
point of view worm what's it's very
tricky to defend for white he played
Ruby five obviously intending something
something similar but the problem is
right has a good defense just one
defense but it's it's efficient he
played Queen d3 and this seems to save
the issue okay I'm not saying that the
other move would have won Queen everyone
check but after Queen d3 the worst is
definitely over the problem is that
gathers rookies just hanging if the
Queen moves away and the only way to
keep stuff on the Border's chest like
that then King f2 white will be able to
get back and in this position for
instances even a threat of playing see
form so it's really some some progress
that white made that black heavy pieces
are simply not that active yeah in the
game um and exchanged Queens not not
quickly because it's basically
acknowledging that this will be a draw
takes and now black approaches the the
King approaches to the center with the
king but why it is just too active he
tossed the deep on right away to
activate Black could could have taken it
hurts yep Dwight place just king here to
attack it and deflect tries to keep you
get over and will
get the beep or later it's just white is
playing with an extra king now the
active King is now helpful in the rook
endgame there is nothing to do here
unplayed miss King to the center and
here after that check check here they
agree to a draw and yeah white will
always get this this spawn back and
there's no progress to be made anywhere
yeah a draw maybe I mount had slight
chances with Queen f1 it's hard to tell
if this was anything substantial or if
he would have had serious winning
chances I am very very difficult I mean
I don't want to make a super long video
on that so maybe this was the way to try
to set more problems so the Queen to f1
here instead of this would be five move
ok a draw not a brilliant result for for
both players but certainly a decent one
you need to keep in mind if you expect I
don't know some some heavier so would
assault from black here in this game and
it has plus 2 is got two wins and his
back already and he has a win against
Aronian which is very important for any
tie break so in case of an enduro nyan
finishing on equal points he has a win
in the back and the first tie break is
the direct result against each other so
unless Aronian is beating on Anand in
the in the second half of the tournament
he will have the better tie break
against aronian so just assume they play
a draw in the second game and other than
that they finish on the same points
Anand is the one to qualify because he
has to swing from round one um so he's
in a really comfortable position with
the plus two and I mean last year plus 3
was sufficient to qualify so
it is a perfectly acceptable strategy
now for him to play solidly and hope to
to get those two let's say two points
plus 4 as excellent not losing against
one of his main rivals and it's
perfectly okay you don't need to do
anything too fancy here and he got some
chances even with this relatively tried
opening so nothing to do to have the
heavily criticized yeah I believe all
right I hope you enjoyed it thanks for
watching